[Musique]
aussi certains enjeux liés aux
transports que doivent assumer les
familles d'accueil que ce soit pour les
suivis médicaux dans la ville d'origine
ou pour entretenir le lien avec la
famille biologique aux enjeux de
distance s'ajoutent les contraintes
financières puisque le ministère prévoit
un dédommagement quotidiens de 12
dollars par enfant pour la nourriture et
pour les produits génétiques plusieurs
familles d'accueil dénoncent également
la charge administrative notamment pour
les plans d'intervention et les
interactions avec les établissements de
placement
que vraiment si on a beaucoup de
familles d'accueil qui se désistent à
cause d'une tenue de livre qui
qui est aussi importante que ça mais
peut-être que ça n'en fait partie la DPJ
soutient plutôt que la cause principale
la pénurie serait le manque
d'information tant pour les nouvelles
familles que pour les familles d'accueil
d'expérience de son côté le ministre
responsable des services sociaux Lionel
karma a décliné notre demande entrevue
ici Guillaume Renaud Radio-Canada Juana